طرح الاعلان الترويجي لطاش العوده هو
المنصات تشتعل حماه سوى السرقه التنين في
ليبيا العالم بيحقق والناس بتسال سرقه كيف
والخطر ايش هو في مانشستر سيتي حب مدرب
الفريق لجوليا روبرتس يفجر ازمه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
واحد من اشهر المسلسلات السعوديه لا بل
والعربيه واللي صار خلص من كلاسيكيات
الدراما ناقش مختلف القضايا الاجتماعيه
للمجتمع السعودي على مدار 17 سنه فبدا من
93 وتوقف في 2008 كم سنه ورجع بعدها في
2011 وتوقف بعد عرض الجزء ال18 ومن اشهر
كشف رئيس هيئه الترفيه المستشار تركي ال
الشيخ عن مفاجاه بعوده المسلسل في جزء
جديد في رمضان المقبل بعد توقف 12 سنه
وبمشاركه نجميه كمان ناصر القصبي وعبد
الله السدحان وليله امس نشر الاعلان
الترويجي للمسلسل اللي هو واحد من اكثر
الاعمال المنتظره وللجمهور مترقبها
ومترقبه الجديد اللي حيعملوه بعد كل سنين
التوقف هذه هو الاعلان اعتمد على الشخصيات
الكرتونيه الاعلان عوده طاش
[موسيقى]
ضروري بس
العوده
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
حماس الناس على الاعلان هذا الترجم في
المشاهدات اكثر من مليون مشاهده على حساب
ابو ناصر اللي نشر الاعلان هذا غير الكويت
والكومنتات وهذه عينه من كمان حماس
الجمهور لعوده طاش
[موسيقى]
واحد من اهم اخبار اليوم جيم من ليبيا
فوثيقه سريه للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه كشفت فقدان 2.5 من اليورانيوم
الطبيعي من احد البواقع في ليبيا من
البيان السري كان للمدير العام للوكاله
ووصلت نسخه منه للاعلام وفي بيقول انه في
زياره تفتيشيه لموقع من اللي كانت مخزنه
في كميات من اليورانيوم الطبيعي وادي
زياره اجل السنه عشان الاوضاع الامنيه في
ليبيا الان لمن قامت فيها الوكاله
المفتشين انه في عشره اسطوانات بتحتوي على
اثنين ونص طن من اليورانيوم مو موجوده في
الموقع وتابع البيان ان الوكاله راح تكمل
اجراءاتها علشان تعرف ملابسات ازاله
اليورانيوم من المكان اللي تم التحفظ على
اسمه وما قيل عنه الا انه مو تحت سيطره
الحكومه هذا الاعلان قلبت الدنيا من اولا
سياسيا عن اللي سرقوا كفن سرقوا وهذا
النوع من الاسئله لكن كمان على الجانب
الاخر قلب الدنيا مخاوف بتتعلق بالسلامه
وانتشار الاسلحه خاصه من قبل خبراء
الانتشار النووي فهؤلاء وكاله الطاقه
الذريه بيحدروا ان الجهل باستخدام هذه
المواد يمكن يشكل خطر اشعاعي هذا غير انه
قالوا كمان انه كل طن يورانيوم طبيعي ممكن
يتحول لخمسه فاصله سته كيلو جرام مواد
مستخدمه في الاسلحه وهذا بيجعل العثور على
المعدن ام المفقود امر عاجل وخطير حقيقي
هنا يعني في اسئله كثيره صراحه اولا كل طن
يورانيوم بيعمل خمسه كيلو مواد مستخدمه في
سلاح فقط هذه يعتبر كثير وخطير يعني تانين
قديش خطر انه ينسرق هذا اليورانيوم واصلا
اليورانيوم بكون باي حاله مخزن واي احد
ممكن يصنع منه سلاح يعني الان يعني
الموضوع يحتاج معرفه او مثلا يعني منشات
ضخمه يعني على العموم من الاسكندريه دكتور
علي عبد النبي نائب رئيس المحطات النوويه
سابقا وخبير الطاقه اهلا فيك معانا دكتور
علي اول شيء الكميه اللي بنتكلم عنها
وبتقول وكاله
طاقه انه لازم يتم استرجاعها على الفور هي
فعلا كميه يعني خطيره لهذه الدرجه
طبعا يعني اولا بشكركم على استضافتي في
البرنامج
الموضوع امبارح
يعني
تقرير عن هذا الموضوع
والكميه طبعا لا يستهان بها اثنين ونص طن
عشر اسطوانات
هو من خمر يورانيوم ممكن يكون خام طبيعي
او ممكن يكون خام منافقه اللي هو العجينه
الصفرا او الكيكه الصفرا
هم قالوا ان هي الكعكه الصفراء او الكعكه
الصفراء يعني ايا كان
[موسيقى]
الكميه دي كميه كبيره اولا ما فيش جهه
حكوميه ليبيه
يعني قالت ان هي المسؤوله عن هذا الموضوع
طبعا الموضوع انا شايفه ان هو
تحت مسمى سرقه
مواد نوويه طبعا الخوف ان هو يصل الى
ايادي الجامعات الارهابيه لان ممكن
يستخدموه النهارده القناه النوويه القذره
بتستخدم
العجينه الصفرا او يعني
او بتستخدمه كخام اليورانيوم اكسيد
اليورانيوم طبعا الاشعه اللي بتطلع
لما انت تقول كيكه ايش يعني
يعني هي هو نفس الخامه اللي جايه من من
باطن الارض لكن
لها نوع من الكرش ونوع من التنظيف بحيث ان
هي كانت يعني تبقى يورانيوم خام صافي ما
يبقاش في معاش شوائب اخرى طيب الان الجهه
اللي سرقتها يعني
تقدر بكل سهوله مثلا انه تعمل منها سلاح
يعني
اه ممكن تعمل منها قنبله قذره قنبله نوويه
القذره القنبله النوويه القذره ده بتاخد
البودر ده او البودره دي اللي هي البودره
وبتحاول تنشرها في الجو بحيث ان
يعني الناس تستنشق هذا
التراب او هذا العفره بيدخل في صدرها او
بينزل في التربه النبات يمتصه الحيوان
بيبقى في المواد المشعه دي طبعا على المدى
الطويل بيحصل ت
يعني التجمع يعني جراحات متراكمه ممكن
يسبب سرطان
سرطان الرئه وده فيها خطوره كبيره يعني
ايه الشائع هذا الموضوع انه فجاه كده
ينقال انه في رانيا مختفى
والله هو ده
الخبراء
الوكاله اللي
هم الموضوع وممكن يكون فيها حاجات تانيه
يعني لان طبعا ليبيا غير مستقره يعني
في جزء يعني طرفين بيتنازعوا على حكم
ليبيا ومشاكل بينهم وحروب بينهم فطبعا
الاداره طبعا في ازمه امنيه وفي جهات
كثيره هتستفيد ممكن من سرقه هذه المواد
وحتى بيعها سواء في السوق السوداء او
بيعها الدول او او او
الجامعات الارهابيه ده الفيروس
الممتاز ده ان هي
تنشر الفساد في المجتمع اللي هو منحل زي
المجتمع الليبي سياسيه المنحل يعني مفيش
دوله ليبيه فين دوله ليبيا دلوقتي ما فيش
ممكن تستغلها
ايوه تمام طيب نكف لما بيجوا بيسرقوها بس
يعني هي الواحد لما بيشوف البيانات هذه
يعني بحس انهم كانهم يعني جايبين انه كده
سياره ومحملينا اليوراني ومطلعين فيهم كده
بيعملوها فعلا
اوكي خلي بالك
الاتنين ونص طن دولت يعني حجمهم صغير مش
كبير لان اليورانيوم كشفته عاليه
اوكي
فهو بيبقى حاجه اقيمته الماديه هذا مثلا
هذه اللي بنتحدث عنهم الاثنين طن قد ايش
ممكن تكون
يعني الاوقيه بتوصل
اوكي يعني
بس انت بتتكلم مع واحده صفر اوقيه صفر
رياضيات صفر كذا فيعني يعني اعطيني كذا
بشكل عام اثنين طن بكم
لكن يعني
هو غني بالشرخيص لان
التعدين في او الماينينج في بياخد
تكاليف عاليه فهو هو غالي يعني انا ممكن
الكيلو ب 100 دولار مثلا يعني
ممكن اكتر 100 دولار ممكن اكتر من 100
دولار اوكي طيب احنا احنا بنشكرك على هذه
المداخله كان معنا من الاسكندريه دكتور
علي عبد النبي نائب رئيس المحطات النوويه
سابقا وخبير الطاقه شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
اهلا من جديد الممثله والموديل الاسبانيه
هبه بوك زوجه اللاعب المغربي اشرف حكيمي
من وقت ما تم اتهام زوجها بقضيه الاغتصاب
كل الانظار عليها مع انها ما علقت ولد
كلمت عن الموضوع ولا حتى كان لها اي رده
فعل واتضح انها كانت مقدمه رسميا طلب طلاق
من قبل ما يتم اتهامه بقضيه الاغتصاب
باسابيع اليوم هبه عبوق متصدره محركات
البحث والمنصات والسبب فيديو متداول لها
خلينا نشوفه مع بعض
تم تداوله بشكل كبير جدا على المنصات وقلب
الدنيا والناس شافته وانقسموا في الاراء
بين اللي قال لها برافو وهذه رده فعل
متوقعه وبين من عنون الفيديو زوجه حكيمي
تتخلى عنه في اوقاته العصيبه وبين اللي
اعتبروها بتهاجم زوجها ولكن المفاجاه كانت
وقت ما بحثتوا الناس عن حقيقه الفيديو
اللي تبين انه الفيديو صحيح ومو صحيح كيف
يعني الفيديو اللي هبه فعليا لكنه اولا مو
جديد تاريخه يعود لي 17 فبراير وقت ما
كانت هبه ابوك في حفل نظمته شركه بولغري
بعيده او بعيدها الخمسه وسبعين والفيديو
منشور على الموقع الاسباني نوفوماس يعني
قبل قضيه الاغتصاب اللي انتشرت في 25
فبراير اما ليه بنقول مو صحيح لانه
الترجمه اللي طالعه على الفيديو ما لها اي
علاقه بقضيه الاغتصاب اصلا فهيبه كانت
بتجاوب صحفي سالها عن اولادها والفرق
بينهم شوفوا الان الترجمه الصحيحه للمقطع
مدرب كره قدم اسبانيا
منها الدوري الانجليزي لكن كمان دوري
ابطال او خلينا نقول انه لكن دوري ابطال
اوروبا تحديدا لسه مستعصي عليه معاهم
غوارديولا حقق هذا اللقب مع برشلونه فقط
مانشستر سيتي اصلا في حياتهم ما اخذوا
اللقب هذا لا معك غيره طبيعي انه يصير
ينسال كثير غوارديولا عن هذا اللقب اول
امس كان في مباراه لمانشستر سيتي كسبها
سبعه صفر وكان الجوارديول لمؤتمر صحفي بعد
المباراه وفي فاجا الناس فالمدرب يعني
مثل ما بيقولوا بالانجليزي الكثير ناس في
عالم كره القدم والتدريبة لكن في المؤتمر
هذا
هو عن حبه وتقديره للي بيعتبرهم هو ايدلز
عنده وبصراحه فجاه كتير ناس
اوكي
مثل ما شفته عن حبه
الشديده انها يوم ما زالت
بريطانيا راحت زارت مانشستر يونايتد جاتهم
الرجال خلينا نقول الجوارديولا يعني بحبها
لدرجه معتبر انه لو ايش ما عمل شايف نفسه
فاشل لانه يوم ما زارت بريطانيا ما جات لي
مانشستر سيتي اللافت اكثر في الموضوع انه
الزياره اللي بيتكلم عنها غوارديولا كانت
في 2016
قرر يعمق جراحه اكثر وقام ناشر على
حساباته وصور من زياره جوليو روبرس للنادي
وعنوان هابي تروبا
تصريح جوارديولا هذا عن حبه لجولي روبرت
في اعتبارهم نفسه فاشل ايش ما حقك في
حياته لانه ما جات زارتهم كثار ناس شافوه
تعليق دمه خفيف وحتى تفهموا احساسه يعني
وحسوا انه لو ما كانوا يعني حيكونوا عندهم
نفس الشعور يعني
كمان يعني لكن في كثير ناس وتحديدا من
معجبين النادي مان سيتي ضد من مدرب فريقهم
وما عجبهم كلامه وشافوا انه في اهانه
وتقليل من النادي وما يجوز كده
طيب
الموضوع مو بس عمل ازمه لكن كمان تحول
لموضوع اسئله لناس تانيه ما لها اي علاقه
في الموضوع فمدرب ارسنال لقي نفسه في
مؤتمر صحفي بنسال مين الايضول حقهونك اللي
نفسك انهم يجوا يزوروا النادي
[موسيقى]
من بعد اشهر على بدايه الموسم الاول من
برنامج المسابقات الغنائي ساودي ايدل تم
امس تتويج الفائز في اللقب واللي كان من
نصيب المتسابقه همس فكري
محبوب السعوديه
[موسيقى]
الف مبروك لك يا همس
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الف مبروك لهمس
فازت واستحقت لقب سعودي
العزيز وماجد ايضا نجوم وكلهم يستحقون
وصولهم لهذه المرحله كل المشتركين اللي
وصلوا معنا اصلا لسعود عادل هم فعلا نجوم
ساره
تاثر هامس كان واضح لحظه اعلان فوزا مثل
ما شفنا وكان واضح كمان في كلمه وجهتها
بعد الفوز لكل امراه سعوديه
بحب اشكر بلادي السعوديه بلاد الحرمين
رؤيه 2030 اللي قدمت لنا مسامحت لنا
الفرصه ان احنا نوصل لهذا المكان شكرا ملك
سلمان شكرا ولي العهد تركي ما علينا شكرا
ما علينا تركي على الشيخ
بلاد العز والخير والفخر اقول لهم شكرا
واوعدكم باذن الله اني اطور من نفسي واكون
عند حسن ظنكم باذن الله ان شاء الله انتم
اجمل ناس قابلتهم في حياتي بليز قدموا على
سعودي ايدل كل مره سعوديه لازم تطمح وتحقق
حلمه من الان ان كان عندك موهبه الغناء
قدميها بلادنا السعوديه سامحتنا من الفرصه
ان احنا نقدم فيها احبك وان شاء الله انك
تكونين فخوره فيني احنا تعبنا وحققنا
احلامنا بنتي حبيبتي روحي انا اهديك نجاح
وفوزي بكل ما فيني من معاني
هذه النسخه هي الاولى من ايدول وكانت
برعايه هيئه الترفيه ورئيسها المستشار
تركي ال الشيخ امس نشر تغريده بارك عبر
للمتسابقه هامس فكري باللقب وقالوا انه
سعيد بالشراكه بين هيئه الترفيه ومجموعه
ام بي سي همس فكري كانت واحده من بين
مجموعه من المتسابقين اللي لفتوا الانظار
في البرنامج ومن وقت يعني ظهورها في تجارب
الاداء لفتاه الانبار انا راح اترككم مع
مقطع مما غنت خلال مشاركتها وعود القاكم
الاسبوع المقبل ان شاء الله في امان الله
روحي
ومملكه يداير فداه
ووطني الحبيب
والمحب سواه
[موسيقى]
مرت الايام
على شاني معك يبين
[موسيقى]